-My first guest is
an Emmy winner, a Tony winner,
and a "New York Times"
best-selling author.
He is the star
and executive producer
of the Showtime series
"Your Honor,"
which airs Sunday nights
at 10:00 p.m.
Here he is, the one and only
Bryan Cranston!
Ah, look at you!
-Hey, Jimmy.
-You are the best.
You're looking good, buddy.
We love it when you stop by,
and we appreciate it
always, always, always.
Thank you for going above and
beyond and doing "Fancy Soaps."
That was fun.
-It just so happens that
I am a fancy soap collector,
and you didn't even know that.
-[ Laughs ]
I did not know that.
-Amazing.
-I didn't realize this, but soap
actually plays a big part
in your acting career.
One of your first gigs
was a soap commercial,
and we have a photo.
Here's a shot of Bryan Cranston
in his Shield Soap commercial.
That's a stud right there.
Come on.
Do you remember
getting this gig?
-Yeah, look at that young man.
Yeah, I do remember.
[ Clears throat ]
In order to get
a soap commercial,
you got to go in really stinky.
-Ah.
-That's good to know.
-I mean, yeah, it is after big
garlic meal the night before...
-Yeah, I got you.
-...and a few drinks stinky
and then running in sweats
and then coming in,
because then they have to show
that the product really works.
-Something else I did not
really know about you --
but before your acting career
took off,
you were briefly
a stand-up comedian.
What got you into stand-up?
Do you remember?
-Yeah. You know, Jimmy,
it comes more naturally to you,
but it didn't come naturally
to me.
I was afraid of it.
I think the only reason that
I thought
I should do some stand-up
is because it frightened me,
and just the idea
of you're alone onstage,
a microphone and a light
shining on you, and that's it.
Go.
And I thought, "Wow, to be able
to do that would be amazing."
So I took a class and started
writing some material
and went around
to The Comedy Store
and the Improv
and The Laff Stop
and the Playboy Club
out here in Los Angeles
and did the routine.
I never got paid for it,
nor should I
ever have been paid for it.
-Nope.
-I just did the open-mic nights,
and I rose from --
I rose all the way up to
the lofty position of mediocre.
-Oh. [ Laughs ]
Congratulations.
Oh, my God.
-I got up.
-Wow. You got all the way up
to mediocre, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Do you remember any of your --
any of your set at all,
any jokes?
-Well, the one
that really worked the best
was when I was talking about
how the plight of car sales
in the country have gone down
and, you know,
particularly men --
much more women
are buying cars than men.
I said there's an easy way
for men to buy cars --
just name them
after women's body parts.
It's like...
-Oh, yeah.
-"Guys, how about
the perky little Ford Nipple?"
-[ Laughs and applauds ]
Yeah.
-"That's an adorable
little guy."
-Dude, that's actually
a good bit.
That would work right now,
by the way.
That would totally work
right now.
I see already it already.
Well, earlier in your intro,
I was -- I was --
I was listing your awards.
You won a Tony.
You won an Emmy.
You're a "New York Times"
best-selling author.
But you've won another award --
you have
an award-winning mezcal.
-Yeah.
-This is major.
-We just won Double Gold, yeah,
from "Cigar & Spirits Magazine."
Dos Hombres, and I --
-Dos Hombres Mezcal.
-Dos Hombres.
-And you and Aaron Paul
got together,
and you guys started --
How did that happen?
I love this.
-You know, about three years
after the end of "Breaking Bad,"
we were in New York together,
having dinner,
and we hadn't seen each other
a lot since then.
It was, "God, I miss you.
You know, we used to see
each other all the time,
and it was so intimate, and
we were really good friends,"
but life goes on
and you move on to other things.
And he said,
"You know, what we ought to do
is start a mezcal company."
And I went, "You're kidding.
The thing with the worm
at the bottom?"
He goes, "No, that's
a BS marketing thing, no.
I mean, really good mezcal."
-No, but you're right.
You're right -- It was that.
That was it.
That's what I knew it as.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, that was
horrible and cheap.
This is unbelievable.
He took me to a mezcal bar.
We tasted a bunch
of different kinds,
and I said, "This is delicious."
We went down to Oaxaca
for a week
and tested and tasted
about 80 different mezcals
until we found Dos Hombres.
And it is -- it's just
a beautiful spirit...
-Just delicious and smoky.
-...old-world, gluten-free --
it's fantastic.
-I have some,
and it's actually delicious.
I love it.
-It's delicious.
-But that's crazy
that you just do that
just out of love
of missing each other
and you go,
"Yeah, let's just do this
so we're forced to talk
to each other and hang out."
-[ Laughs ] So --
Yeah, but there's reason
for us to talk to each other
every day, yeah.
-Hey, I want to talk about your
Showtime series "Your Honor."
For those who haven't seen it,
can you set this up?
-Yeah.
"Your Honor" is about a superior
court judge and his son.
His son is 17, a sweet kid,
and he unfortunately
gets involved
in a traffic accident
where a boy dies,
and he panics, and he leaves
the scene of the accident,
thereby becoming a crime scene.
When he tells me
and confesses what happened,
I tell him, "You've got
to do the right thing.
You have to be accountable
for your actions."
And I convince him --
we're going to turn him in
to the police
and go through the system.
When we get to
the police station,
I notice the parents of the boy
who died that morning,
and the man, the father,
is a vicious mob boss,
and I know that
that man will kill my son,
regardless of whose fault
it was or anything.
And so,
with that new information,
I realize I can't just
turn my son in to be killed --
I have to protect him.
So we do an about-face,
and we leave.
-Yeah.
-And from that point on,
we reverse-engineer
everything that happened,
creating alibis,
destroying evidence,
manipulating the jury system,
and the whole thing,
and, of course,
it's a downward spiral.
It's very tense, very emotional.
-Yeah.
-I just didn't thank that
the society had
enough anxiety in their lives,
so, like, we're contributing.
-[ Laughs ]
You think people need more? No.
But by the way...
-We need more.
-...it's a hit, and congrats.
And I know
you direct the finale.
-Yeah.
-Coming up.
-Yeah, I direct the 10th episode
of it, and it's --
you know, it is very interesting
directing yourself.
The director me will
always approach the actor me
and say something like,
"Wow, I mean,
you're a lot better-looking
than I thought you were."
-[ Laughs ]
-And...
-Slow clap.
-And then, the actor me
gets flustered
and feels the flirtation
and sleeps with the director.
-Ohh.
-It's kind of nasty, really.
-How long have you been
sleeping with the director?
-Oh, many years.
-Wow.
-And it hasn't gotten me
very far.
I'm always disappointed, too.
-[ Laughs ] Oh, my gosh.
-Really.
It's like, "Is that it?
Really? That's all?"
-That was all.
-Hm.
-Yeah.
-I liked the flirting better.
Well, here's Bryan Cranston...
-Yeah.
-...not necessarily directed
by Bryan Cranston,
in "Your Honor."
Take a look at this.
-12 of our peers will do
exactly what I want them to do.
Tomorrow or the next day,
I am making a move.
Now, are we done here?
-Only number in here is mine.
I want to know what you've done
and when you've done it,
and I want it by 10:00 a.m.
the day after tomorrow.
Let's call that a deadline,
and let's give that word
its literal meaning.
♪♪
-Bryan Cranston, everybody.
Check out "Your Honor"
Sunday nights at 10:00 p.m.
on Showtime.